scientific and medical research play
increasingly important roles in our
lives which means that the accuracy of
what we read and hear about them is
increasingly important as well how can
society make good decisions on complex
subjects such as global warming
environmental protection public health
or genetic engineering if we can't trust
what's reported about them and yet we
seem to be bombarded by contradictory
information about these fields news
about nutrition seems particularly
inconsistent and subject to trends if
the Atkins diet good for you or not how
about the Paleo diet should you be on a
low-fat diet what about a high-fat diet
what's healthier butter or margarine
should you use sugar substitutes or
avoid them part of the reason science
and health news can be so confusing and
frustrating is the very nature of
science itself scientific knowledge is
always changing and by its nature it is
uncertain new discoveries are constantly
rendering previous beliefs obsolete at
the same time when the great weight of
evidence favors a particular conclusion
there's good reason to believe it the
news media don't always do a good job of
explaining scientific findings or
putting them in proper context they also
compete for the public's attention with
misinformation which sometimes comes
from parties whose interests are
threatened by what researchers have
found let's take a close look at how to
make sense of science and health news
and how to distinguish the news you can
trust from the news you can't to start
it's important to have a clear
understanding of the scientific method
Robert Niles writing an online
journalism review in 2011 summarized it
nicely in 7 steps 1 find a topic or
question worth exploring to do some
initial background research to learn
about your topic or question read what's
been written before 3 come up with a
hypothesis this
your best guess of what has happened
what is happening or what will happen
based upon what you already know for
test your hypothesis you can do this by
collecting data either through
controlled experimentation or
observation 5 look at and analyze your
data 6 based on your analysis either
accept or reject your hypothesis 7
publish your information including all
relevant details on how you collected
and analyzed your data notice the
open-mindedness that the scientific
process requires to find a topic or
question to explore our researcher needs
to begin with curiosity which requires
the researcher to accept than what he or
she knows isn't all there is to know the
researcher needs to come up with a
hypothesis for why things are the way
they are but needs to be open to the
possibility that the facts won't bear
that hypothesis out after publishing
research findings the researcher needs
to be open to the possibility that other
research may prove those findings wrong
just as other researchers need to be
open to the possibility that the
findings may be right even once research
findings are widely accepted scientists
still often refer to knowledge they
derive from them as theories gravity for
example is referred to as a theory even
though we all know that there's only one
direction and apples gonna fall from a
tree that's because for all we know
about gravity there's still more we
don't know on things that we think we
know could still be proven wrong from
start to finish the scientific method
demands humility honesty and
transparency in order to achieve
reliable results exaggeration or
suppression of research results or
unsupportive claims about what they
could mean are all completely contrary
to the purpose and spirit of the
endeavor interestingly Robert Niles
argued that the work of the best
journalists takes largely the same
approach as that of scientific
researchers
like scientists journalists develop
hypotheses about why things are the way
they are and then they test those
hypotheses by collecting data from
sources observation public records and
so forth
today they often use social media as a
source of information
although doing so always requires
verification then journalists publish
their findings and again like scientists
they need to be open to the possibility
that those findings are incorrect
unfortunately not all journalists have a
good understanding of a scientific
method and much of the public
misunderstands it as well
my colleague Nina Otero will help us
think through the process many people
think of the scientific method as
something that only scientists and other
researchers use but whether you realize
it or not you actually use it quite
often in your day to day life it's
really just a methodical approach to
solving problems and building your
knowledge of something that you want to
understand for example let's say your
car won't turn on what do you do well
suppose you look closely at the car and
you find no signs of life there's no
sound of the engine turning over and the
lights on the dashboard
don't come on so you might check first
to see if the battery's working maybe
you can borrow a tester for the battery
you might check with alternator that all
probably sounds pretty straightforward
but if you think about it you've just
developed and tested two hypotheses your
first hypothesis is that the battery is
dead through observation and testing you
may rule out the first hypothesis your
second hypothesis is that your
alternator may have gone bad you can
test that hypothesis to to see if you're
correct if you replace the alternator
and the car starts up you've probably
got your answer as to what was wrong
with it but you'll probably want to
observe your car carefully the next few
times you start it to make sure that you
really solve the problem
that's essentially what scientists do
they test hypotheses cautiously draw
conclusions from the results
and keep testing and observing to see
whether their conclusions are correct
let's debrief
what is this example illustrative at the
scientific process first of all it shows
that hypotheses are essential if you
don't have at least a guess as to why
your car won't start you can't do much
more than stomp your feet and call for
help but it also shows that getting too
attached to our hypothesis is a bad idea
if you won't consider any explanation
for why your car won't start other than
that the battery is dead you'll never
even check to see whether the alternator
is working you've got to remain open to
the possibility that you might be wrong
and discard your hypothesis if after
repeated tests the evidence doesn't
support it in the same vein you can only
develop confidence in a hypothesis if
the evidence clearly supports it
scientists usually have to observe or
test a given phenomenon many many times
before they can come to a good
understanding of it inevitably along the
way they will get some things wrong but
it's all part of the process of
searching for scientific truth so now
that you know the basics of the
scientific method how can you tell which
science and health news to believe and
which to ignore there's a lot of
reporting out there on science and
health topics and unfortunately even the
best news organizations sometimes use
overly alarmist language or fail to put
new studies in their proper context but
some key indicators can tell us when
we're reading good informative science
reporting and when we should be more
skeptical about news of scientific
claims we've assembled a science and
health news checklist to help you test
the scientific validity of what's being
reported most of these items summarize
tips from health news review a health
journalism watchdog and from Africa
check a fact-checking organization when
you read a story on a science or health
topic ask yourself the following
questions does the story use hyperbolic
language rarely do scientific studies
yield true breakthrough revolutionary or
gain
treatments and they certainly don't
claim to have discovered miracles
scientists tends to gain knowledge in
small steps what other studies have been
done good scientific research takes
account of the work of others it might
support the work or challenge it but it
doesn't ignore it no single study is
good enough to make scientists reach a
definitive conclusion so a good science
or health news story will place a new
study in the context of past research a
good science reporter will also ask
other scientists who weren't involved in
the new study what they think of its
findings and significance this is
especially important to keep in mind
when you read about research findings
that may surprise you if a study finds
that broccoli is bad for you or that
smoking doesn't cause cancer ask
yourself if that new study really could
be credible given what most scientists
think and what past scientific research
has shown what was the sample size if
this was a Health Study how many people
participated in it statistically data
from hundreds or thousands of people is
generally more reliable than data from
just say 10 smaller studies involving
just a few people are often just pilot
research that's conducted to determine
whether doing a larger study makes sense
any good science or health reporter
should know that the results of such
pilot studies carry little weight on
their own and if a news story relies on
anecdotes alone that's even less
reliable the sample size is even smaller
than you'd find in any scientific study
anecdotes in a new story can serve to
illustrate a problem or a point but by
themselves they yield terrible data of
mice or men lots of medical studies get
conducted on rodents first this lays the
groundwork for human studies but just
because you see a certain effect in mice
doesn't mean you can expect the same
result in people do the reported
findings show causation or mere
correlation two things can be correlated
or
systematically associated without one
causing the other for example it's been
observed that as ice cream sales
increase so to do drowning deaths does
this mean that ice cream causes drowning
why would that be if you look more
closely at the data you'll see that
increases in ice cream sales and
drowning deaths both occur during the
summer months instead of the increase in
one factor causing an increase in the
other it seems more probable that as the
weather gets warmer ice cream sales and
drowning deaths increase independently
Tyler vegan a Harvard Law student
created a website called spurious
correlations that's full of such curious
pairings for example it shows that as
per capita margarine consumption in
Maine declined between the year 2000 and
2009
so did divorce rates is it really
possible that eating less margarine
leads to fewer divorces or the other way
around
possible sure but highly unlikely cut
back on margarine if you want to but in
all probability this is another case of
correlation without causation a lot of
scientific stories report the two
phenomena have been correlated or linked
but that does not mean that one has been
determined to cause the other in order
to demonstrate a causal relationship
convincingly researchers need to perform
specific types of statistical tests on
the data such as regression or employ
specific research methodologies such as
randomized control trials the fact that
they have correlated two phenomena might
mean that one causes the other but as a
reader you should proceed with caution
instead of leaping to conclusions if the
story is about a medical treatment does
it talk about cost and availability lots
of newly discovered medical treatments
are described as promising but if the
treatment is too expensive for most
people to use it may not make much
difference or not until the price comes
down also stories often hype up new
treatments long before they're actually
available to the public look
see whether the story is just talking
about research or whether it describes
actual plans to release and market the
treatment does the story provide details
on a treatments benefits and harms first
benefits how effective is the treatment
is this quantified and what about
possible harms few treatments are
without their side-effects
what are these what about potential
interactions with other drugs if these
aren't mentioned the article isn't very
trustworthy it's the story engaging in
disease mongering sometimes the story
will exaggerate the severity of a
condition or medicalize what's actually
a normal state of health in the late
1970s for example being shy was not a
medical condition by the early 1990s it
was widely considered a mental disorder
and was treated with antidepressants you
can decide for yourself whether that's a
good thing but if you see an article
medicalize what seems to you to be an
ordinary state of health it may be a
sign that the author is interested in
selling your product or treatment rather
than trying to simply inform you about a
new research development is the article
based on research that was published in
a reputable scientific journal if you
want to dig deeper look at the study
that the story is based on is the
journal legitimate real scientific
journals and there are thousands of them
have a rigorous review process to try
and make sure that studies were carried
out well and results are accurate
however just as there are fake news
publishers there are fake journals who
funded the research be careful of
conflicts of interest if the study that
you're reading is about the health
effects of sugar was it funded by a soda
company but remember that research costs
money and someone has to pay for it
oftentimes it's a government even
industry fuddy funded studies can often
be good science just think about whether
the research findings benefit the
industry or not and if they do look
closely at how the study was conducted
if you want to review the points I just
covered you can find a worksheet listing
the same markers of scientific validity
in the guidebook for this course if
you'd like to practice looking for those
markers and reporting or digital content
there's also a chart in the guidebook to
help prompt your questioning and a
couple of sample articles to practice on
once you've gone through the exercise a
couple of times you'll become more
accustomed to asking yourself basic
verification questions when you
encounter new science and health
information let's return now to the
subject of anecdotal evidence which I
mentioned earlier because it plays an
especially problematic role in health
information that circulates on the web
and in social media there are many
health related websites some of them are
valid and provide useful information
some of them are the personal projects
of non experts while others are selling
products in the guise of operating
objective health advice often they make
claims in the form of stories about
individuals who allegedly benefited from
a particular medicine or treatment you
may receive a similar kind of input from
friends or friends of friends on social
media they may sing the praises of a
product or treatment that they say help
them and while it's easy to be skeptical
of anecdotal information in theory when
someone we know and trust swears that
something was effective for them it can
be easier to be taken in here are some
of the key reasons to be wary of
anecdotal information about medical
cures self-limiting illnesses
some illnesses go away with or without
treatment self healing by definition
people who are at the worst point of an
illness get better if they survive if
someone takes a particular medication at
that low point and gets better that may
seem like proof that the medication
solve the problem but it also might have
done nothing and the person got better
anyway multiple treatments if someone
tells you they're using several medical
treatments at once and gets better
how can you
which one if any was the cure
confirmation bias as we've seen
previously people tend to see the
results they want to see especially if
they're paying a lot of money for a
treatment poor recall we have a hard
time remembering the fluctuations and
how we feel from day to day when people
try to reconstruct those memories their
prey to confirmation bias placebo
response getting treatment makes people
feel subjectively better even if the
treatment isn't actually doing anything
to their bodies side effects as I noted
earlier it's important to ascertain not
only if a treatment works but if it's
likely to cause serious side effects
anecdotal information that one person
suffered no side effects isn't a
reliable indication of whether you will
or won't suffer them yourself dead men
tell no tales those for whom a
miraculous extract didn't work are
unlikely to give testimonials and people
who die can never tell us what they
thought of their treatment we're gonna
turn to Nina again to practice
identifying some of the flaws and
anecdotal health information let's say
that your best friend Juan was suffering
from a bad flu he tried ibuprofen but he
just felt worse and worse so he did two
sessions with a certified master of
Reiki the form of alternative medicine
also known as energy healing he began
feeling better after three sessions his
flu was gone he concluded that raking
works is this a sensible conclusion that
can support your friends help decision
making in the future or your own why or
why not
well you might really care about your
friend Juan but it may be that there
were some other reasons that he got
better for example it could be that Juan
was already at the worst point of his
illness he just recovered on his own or
this might be a case of confirmation
bias one may have just seen the results
he wanted to see one might have had an
extra incentive to do so
if the
Reiki treatments were expensive
alternately one wise experienced might
be a classic placebo response getting
the treatment may have actually made him
feel better even if the treatment didn't
really heal him all these explanations
are possible the problem is that we
don't know which one to believe if any
because all we have to go on is Juan's
anecdote we have no other evidence to
consider here's another situation on
Facebook your old school friend Tatiana
announced that she was diagnosed with
breast cancer she later said that green
tea extract helped relieve her nausea
from chemotherapy and it eventually
killed off the tumor
she's now cancer-free so she says the
green tea extract works you're naturally
happy for her but consider it could be
that she was getting multiple treatments
if she used several at once how can she
tell what made her better it's likely
that the chemotherapy not the green tea
extract eliminated the tumor maybe
Tatiana just has poor recall it can be
hard to remember the fluctuations in how
we feel from day to day and when we try
to remember where prates a confirmation
bias nausea is never as bad when we will
call it as it was in the moment
so Tatiana's anecdotal information is as
unreliable as wand was let's look at one
last example suppose your aunt Florence
has suffered from chronic pain for over
20 years she heard about vitamin b6 on
their news she started taking super high
doses six weeks ago she feels better now
on most days so she concludes that b6
works she might be right but then again
this could be another case of placebo
response as with whan the vitamins may
be making Florence subjectively feel
better even if they aren't actually
doing anything to her body and in fact
the vitamins might be doing bad things
to Florence's body just because she
feels good now doesn't mean that taking
them is good for her in fact in high
doses vitamin b6 can cause serious side
effects for example it can damage the
nerves here as in the other two examples
anecdotal evidence doesn't give us
enough information to make a good
decision if you have chronic pain you'd
be much better off checking with your
doctor or looking to reliable web-based
resources than relying on your aunt's
personal experiences which web resources
can we you count on for accurate health
news unfortunately bad sources of health
information far outnumber good sources
on the web but there are some highly
reliable and easy to use resources that
we can recommend to you and you'll find
a list of them in the guidebook
accompanying this course here's a couple
of examples of how you can put these
resources to use let's say your friend
Karen is feeling depressed her cousin
recommended that she takes st. John's
wort Karen has turned to you for your
advice what would you advise her one
good place to research supplements is
the Cochrane Library it reviews
thousands of studies and provides
overviews in layman's terms of current
scientific findings on health topics
type st. John's wort into the search box
and click on the first study to appear
from the search let's say it's st.
John's worked for major depression then
scroll down to plain language summary
which summarizes the findings of the
study in layman's terms this will tell
you that trials found that st. John's
work was similarly effective as standard
antidepressants but it seemed less
effective in non german-speaking
countries and flaws in the study could
not be ruled out plus the st. John's
products on the market vary a lot and it
might interact with other drugs to cause
side effects Cochrane advises that
patients wanting to use st. John's wort
should see a health professional or
suppose you're cooking salmon and you
want to make sure
that you're cooking it at a safe
temperature where do you go to find out
the US Food and Drug Administration and
US Department of Agriculture are the
federal agencies that regulate food
safety so for starters Google safe cook
temp salmon USDA you'll soon find a link
for the USDA's website there you can
search for safe minimum internal
temperature which will bring up multiple
results including a chart on the subject
if you click on the chart it will tell
you that fish and shellfish should be
cooked with a minimum internal
temperature of 145 degrees Fahrenheit
enjoy your salmon and the comfort of
knowing that you cooked it properly
learning to check out dubious claims
that you encounter about science and
health is an important way to protect
yourself as well as to avoid passing on
miss information to others make sure to
stay skeptical when you see ads and
publicity for supplements since such
information is only lightly regulated
getting valid and evidence-based science
and health information matters in the
real world the 2019 measles outbreak in
the Pacific Northwest in New York that
we discussed at the outset of this
course an outbreak that was fueled by
low vaccination rates driven by
misinformation about vaccines is one
important example by adopting the
cautious questioning outlook that
scientists themselves have as you read
and share science and health news you
can stay better informed while
supporting the advancement of science
and public health as well
[Music]
[Music]